hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut ich freue
mich sehr jetzt endlich damit anfangen
ihr wisst ja ich bin vor zirka zwei
monaten hier in meine erste eigene
wohnung gezogen
und ja ich hatte schon immer so die
vorstellung dass ich viel ist auch so
smart machen möchte ich wollte am
liebsten halt dass die ganze wohnung zum
smartphone wird natürlich geht das nicht
von null auf hundert und das ganze
braucht noch ein bisschen bis alles
installiert ist und es gibt ja so viele
funktionen die dann immer noch weiterhin
dazu kommen können was aber wirklich
sehr nice ist die telekom ist auf mich
zugekommen mit dem magenta smarthome da
gibt es unfassbar viele sachen die ich
alle jetzt also vieles habe ich hier
halt jetzt drin ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe das meiste davon schon
mal ausgepackt ich habe jetzt hier
nochmal eingepackt damit ich das euch
hier nochmal zeigen kann und wir werden
in diesem video
meine ganze wohnung oder sehr viel in
dieser wohnung smart machen ich zeige
euch das alles es werden am ende die
lichter in jedem raum steuerbar sein
es werden selbst diese lampen steuerbar
sein die kaffeemaschine wird sogar
eventuell steuerbar sein meint auch
roboter kann zum beispiel einfach per
sprache hinweis losfahren usw
es wird der nice und im jahr machen wir
das noch direkt mal auf so sieht das aus
hier sind super viele sachen drin
einfach mal eins nach dem anderen
hier hat man zum beispiel einfach so
eine magenta smarthome led-lampe e27
fassung habe ich das heißt wie zum
beispiel den deckenlampe mit e27 fassung
da kannst du diese lampe rein drehen und
über wlan kann man lieder mit der
agentur smart home home base verknüpfen
das ist eigentlich so das herzstück von
diesem ganzen smart home system dann
haben wir noch andere sachen wie zb
magenta smartphone zwischenstecker das
sind steckdosen die könnt ihr einfach
ganz normal auf eure steckdosen machen
und die dann auch über diese homebase
steuern das heißt zum beispiel diese
ganzen neon zeit zum hintergrund dieser
alle über den mehrfachstecker da unten
geregelt den könnte ich in diesen
zwischenstecker stecken und dann einfach
immer immer meine magenta smartphone-app
das aktivieren wenn man es noch leichter
haben möchte habe ich hier dann aber
auch noch den smart speaker mini
sprachassistent das heißt wir können die
smart home base mit diesem mini speaker
verknüpfen da braucht man dann
zusätzlich noch die halo magenta ab
indem man den smart speaker hinzufügen
kann dann kann man beide apps verknüpfen
und dann geht alles per sprache wir
haben wir dann noch weitere sachen wie
ein band taste denen ich noch nicht
ausprobiert habe dann haben wir hier
noch einen tür und fenster kontakt
erkennt offene fenster und türen das
heißt wenn irgendwo was offen steht
kriegt ihr eine nachricht unser geschenk
für sie alarmsystem für fenster oder
türen schützen ihr zuhause mit magenta
smarthome ich habe jetzt insgesamt schon
vier lampen dann auch noch einige
zwischenstecker ich installiere das
jetzt alles und gebt euch dann gleich
mal eine verirrung tue wenn ich fertig
bin zeigt euch das ganze system es sind
mir echt eine menge arbeit ab wie gesagt
ich habe vieles schon mal ausprobiert
und ja jetzt
kennen wir uns
schnell rein ist es kalt draußen leute
das geht
ich habe ja gesagt wir machen jetzt hier
die kleine und was heißt klein herzlich
willkommen beim einer smartphone punkt
uhr direkt mal durch ins wohnzimmer
[Musik]
achso moment das kann ich erklären
jetzt muss ich noch nicht hier um einen
tempel wieder einstellen dass ich zu
hause bin weil das war meine neue anlage
immer wenn ich jetzt raus unterwegs bin
kann ich die einstellen und sobald
jemand eben eine tür geöffnet und ich
davon nichts weiß dann geht heute der
alarmanlage ich kriegte nachricht das
war jetzt ein kleines feature um
reinzukommen
auf jeden fall dass wohnungsmarkt mein
büro und der flur sind jetzt komplett
ausgestattet ist alle smart die
steckdosen sind smart die lichter sind
smart und es kann alles über du kannst
einfach mit kommen entweder dieses
tablet hier steuern oder ich hab die
smart home agents auch auf meinem handy
ich gebe einfach eine kleine tour und
dann zeige ich euch wie das ganze
funktioniert wir haben hier unten unter
dem fernseher den sprachassistenten dell
mini speaker worüber ich das ganze
auftritt per sprache steuern kann
das heißt wenn ich jetzt keinen bock hab
irgendwie den stecker land zu machen
kann ich auch sagen alle magenta stecker
in wohnste war nicht so und jetzt ist
zum beispiel ja eigentlich diese lampen
etwa um reinzukommen
wir haben also darf
die ganze küchen beleuchtung ist auch
smart gemacht kann ich euch gleich auch
noch zeigen wir haben hier an der decke
kannst du mir hoch filmen einmal mit
meinen led lampen die können ganz
normales licht machen aber auch farbig
leuchten zeige ich euch auch gleich und
das alles wird gesteuert
hier über die smart home base ich habe
hier jetzt erstmal so positioniert um
euch das zu zeigen ist ganz einfach mit
meinem router verknüpft selbst ich habe
die maschine kann ich per sprache jetzt
praktisch haben und ausmachen
das mega cool ich würde sagen ich sage
jetzt erst mal hin erklärt dass einmal
und dann zeige ich euch alle features
mitbringt all das ist echt ein ganz
neues erlebnis hier in meinem zuhause
ok marie du gehst und jetzt bitte in die
pause du hast dein linkes getan
du darfst jetzt seine art von genau und
mir mal die kamera geben
so löse ich erkläre ich's mal wie das
ganze funktioniert wie gesagt ich stehe
eigentlich alles über meinen tablet um
euch das jetzt zu zeigen nämlich mal
mein handy weil da habe ich die app auch
drauf ich kann das jedem bildschirm ab
film auf einem tablet wird das irgendwie
nicht auf jeden fall gehen wir hier
einfach mal in die smartphone magenta f
wir sind hier auf der startseite mein
zuhause da kann man sehen alarmsystem
ist bereit ich habe mich als abwesend
eingetragen ich bin jetzt wieder zu
hause also kann ich wieder ausstellen
danke hier sind meine favoriten also
alle sachen die ich am meisten benutzt
das ist eigentlich ganz cool also wenn
ich jetzt sage ich möchte im wohnzimmer
ein bisschen licht haben kann ich zum
beispiel einfach nur lampe 1 wir an
machen und diese dann an könnt ihr das
gerade zwar nicht sehen aber die sun man
kann hier oben sogar seinen
energieverbrauch sehen dass sich gerade
zum ersten mal auch kraß auf jeden fall
wollte und jetzt mal auf geräte geben
hier sind jetzt meine drei zimmer
eingetragen oder meine drei bäume einer
das büro flur und wohnzimmer
wir befinden uns jetzt gerade im
wohnzimmer und hier sind jetzt alle
sachen aufgeführt die ich hier schon
verknüpft haben lampe 1 und 2 sind
einmal links und rechts hier genau über
mir könnt jetzt gerade nicht sehen und
dann haben wir die stecker einmal der
erste stecker der ist für die
stehleuchte da zuständig und der zweite
stecker ist für die küchen beleuchtung
und gerade auch die kaffeemaschine
zuständig da muss ich noch einen
zusätzlichen stecker kaufen man kann ich
heute die kaffeemaschine auch separat
steuern dann gehen wir hier mal auf mehr
und können jetzt hier noch ein paar
weitere
einstellen wie zum beispiel szenen oder
regel mit regeln habe ich mich
ehrlicherweise noch nicht so wirklich
befasst ich brauche es aber auch nicht
da jeder tag von mir irgendwie anders
aussieht man könnte jetzt hier zum
beispiel einstellen dass jeden tag um 20
oder fernseher an geht das licht geht an
der stecker rät an und das wars oder
halt jeden morgen um 7 uhr geht der
stecker bei der kaffeemaschine an und
die kaffeemaschine fährt hoch ich
brauche das halt nicht weil meine tage
alles andere als geregelt sind also weiß
nicht ob das gut oder schlecht ist wir
gehen hier viel lieber mal in szenen ich
habe mir hier vier szenen eingestellt
das ist eigentlich ganz einfach zu
erklären
ihr könnt in jede szene verschiedene
stecker verschiedene lampen wasser
hinzufügen und die dann einfach immer
ein und ausschalten und dafür auch jetzt
eigentlich noch marie aber die fünf hat
ihre haare also was gleich marie macht
sich gerade noch fertig deswegen macht
das jetzt einfach mal so ich mache jetzt
mal kurz dunkel
hallo magenta schalte die szene
wohnzimmer hinein jetzt nur mal als
beispiel also das habe ich jetzt über
sprachstörungen steuert man kann es
natürlich dann auch einfach über die app
steuern hallo magenta schaltete die
szene party ein
okay das ist noch nicht so gut ich weiß
nun erst mal als beispiel jetzt kann ich
die szene auch wieder ausschalten und
die ihr muss auch noch aus aber dann
habe ich auch noch die szene kochen
jetzt gehen nur diese ansicht zum kochen
braucht
zum schluss werde ich euch gerne doch
meinen videos zeigen das kann ich jetzt
hier einfach einschalten und wegen jetzt
mal rüber in meinem büro zu dann kommen
wir hier rein und wie man sehen kann es
sind alle rechte an die ich für meine
videochat beleuchten braucht einmal hier
das hintergrundlicht da dieser
die auf alle mit stärker gesteuert
werden und ja es ist eigentlich ganz
entspannt oder ach so maria und jetzt
kommst du bitte noch einmal ganz kurz
die tür
das hier an der tür ist nämlich der
optische tür fenster kontakt das heißt
es für die alarmanlage gut jetzt erkennt
er dass die tür auf ist jetzt erkenne
dass die tür zu ist das heißt wenn ich
die alarmanlage einschalte und jemand
reinkommen krieg direkten signal hier
kommt direkt die dual arm und hier haben
wir das heißt wenn diese tür jetzt
aufgeht kriege ich auch signal ich
glaube das weiß man so das richtig sinn
mehr mache ist unfassbar viel spaß ich
dann müsst ihr mit ausnahmen zu setzen
und ich bin mir sicher ich habe mir noch
mehr solche sachen wohin euch dann
natürlich auch gerne immer zeigen ich
habe das video hat euch gefallen in der
video beschreibung verlinkt ihr euch mal
alle sachen von der telekom gesagt das
gerne ab wendet er interessiert seid und
wir sehen uns morgen gibt's neues video
das was mir marie lang für ein